وفي تصريح قبل قليل قال منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي بالبيت
الابيض قال انسحاب الجيش السوداني من
المفاوضات في جده امر مؤسف واضاف ان
واشنطن تريد ان يتوقف القتال وان تصل
المساعدات
تنضم الينا اذا من البيت الابيض مراسله
الجزيره وجده وقف نتحدث عن هذه التصريحات
المتحدث باسم البيت الابيض عين في صورتها
وجد وفي صوره رد الفعل الامريكي حيال هذه
الخطوه
نعم ايمان البيت الابيض كان يعوي كثيرا
على مباحثات جده في ان تفضي الى وقف
الاقتتال المسلح بين قوات الدعم السريع
والقوات والجيش السوداني لكن مع قرار
الجيش السوداني تعليق مشاركته في هذه
المباحثات
عبر قبل قليل
جونكر بمنسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه بمجلس
الامن القومي عن اسفه لاتخاذ الجيش
السوداني هذا القرار بتعليق المشاركه وقال
ان الاداره الامريكيه تريد لهذا القتال ان
يتوقف وبانها اكثر من ذلك تريد ان توصل
المساعدات الى الاشخاص والافراد الذين هم
بامس الحاجه اليها وذلك لانه طالما ان
القتال المسلح متواصل لا يمكن لفرق
المساعدات الانسانيه الوصول الى تلك
المناطق التي يوجد فيها ناس بامس الحاجه
لا يوجد لديهم ماء لا غذاء لدواء والاداره
الامريكيه حاولت اكثر من مره خلال
اتصالاتها المستمره بحسب التصريحات
السابقه للمسؤولين الامريكيين لدى اندلاع
القتال المسلح اكدوا بانهم كانوا على
تواصل مستمر مع الطرفين من اجل منح هدنه
لكي تصل المساعدات الانسانيه الى الافراد
الذين هم بامس الحاجه اليها وبعد ان وافق
الطرفان على مباحثات جده كان هناك ارتياح
كبير في اوساط الاداره الامريكيه ولكن
الان بعد ان هذا القرار بتعليق المشاركه
واضح بان هناك احباط كبير هنا في البيت
الابيض عبر عنه جان كيربي بهذه التصريحات
شكرا لك وجد وقتي مراسله الجزيره كنت معنا
من البيت الابيض في واشنطن